David Jamie congratulations you guys
have made it to the forged and fire
final
and are one step closer to ten thousand
dollars
when you showed up to the forge we asked
you to create a weapon of your own
design using our tools and equipment for
this next round we're sending you back
to your home forges
and you're going to create a weapon of
our choosing
it's time to reveal what that mystery
weapon will be
the Qatar
the guitar is a punching and thrusting
weapon originating from Southeast Asia
it was the special weapon of the
Fearsome rajput Warriors from India who
were said to hunt tigers with a pair of
qatars to prove their skill bravery and
nobility as Warriors
it has a distinctive h-shaped handle
which places the large triangular blade
or blades directly over the wearer's
clenched fist the experienced Warrior
would use the Qatar like an extension of
their arm allowing for fluid fast and
agile attacks in much the same way as
the famous Marvel Superhero Wolverine
uses his deadly claws good luck blade
Smiths we'll see you in five days
yeah
hi I'm Jamie Vining and I'm 28 years old
not having trained under a master
bladesmith everything I know is from
online research and reading in books
I decided to sketch something myself I
am going with a two-bladed guitar
it's a little more unique than your
standard single piece so I'm really
hoping that impresses the judges
my biggest concern for today is
hardening my blades I don't exactly know
what the tempering process should be I
don't know if it'll crack or Warp
does everything seem to go right
doesn't look like the cracks I need to
attach the blades to the handle sharpen
the blade and do a lot of detail work
nothing's going to stop me from getting
this ten thousand dollars
I'm David Goldberg I was born and raised
here in Philadelphia my Japanese name is
kinzon means gold Mountain one bar for
every budo virtue I always make a seven
layer bar for the center of my swords
because
I represent budo I'm a warrior
five days is not enough to make a
masterpiece if you're working at normal
pace so I ramped it up I'm running from
Forge to grinder back to the Hammer to
the Press I'm going crazy
shaping any metal takes a lot of care
and precision it's a make or break it
day
weld's law I noticed a crack on the side
of the blade if it's in there it won't
be good
after all those efforts of blade I'm not
going back with a blade that's
substandard so I'm going to forge
another sword
I put on traditional Japanese work
uniform
in order to set myself up mentally
physically and emotionally
it's going to be tough I'm gonna work
every minute
Ichiban number one is what this says
there can be only one
winning this thing
foreign
balance and ability to slice and slash
we have created this multi-layered
Strike Zone it consists of different
targets at varying positions
Jamie you're first are you ready
absolutely
definitely he's got good swing to it
goes to the air
as a slasher
that will come
good job thank you
David you're up are you ready I'm ready
it is a good Slasher
but I wish you didn't extend this guard
here
has some issues turning my wrist around
good balance though thank you
to test your weapons ability to deliver
a lethal strike I will take your weapons
to punch and thrust into this ballistic
gel dummy that is wearing the kind of
indo-persian armor that these weapons
would face
Dave you're up are you ready I'm ready
foreign
that functioned right through the chain
mail
definitely went right into the heart
that sir is a killer thank you
all right Jamie you're up next you ready
ready
foreign
there it didn't quite go through the
chainmail
but because this splits apart it got in
a little Nick right in there
and on the final kill right above there
it got through
Jamie it will kill thank you
for the strengths test your guitar will
be placed in this pneumatic arm
thrusting device this device is
calibrated so that every thrust is going
to be the same for each of your designs
and just to make it more interesting
we've doubled the layers your Qatar will
have to go through two sheets of metal
Dave are you ready
I'm ready
three two one engage
[Music]
very nice that went right through both
sheets
this blade is strong thank you
okay Jamie we've loaded your Qatar into
the device are you ready I'm ready
in three two one engage
well Jamie it went through the first
sheet of metal it didn't go through the
second sheet of metal
and your alignment on the tips are now
warped but it still went through the
first sheet
good job thank you
Jamie David you've both been outstanding
competitors
however there can only be one forged and
fire champion
David
you are the forged Empire Champion
congratulations
Jamie you did not make the cut the
creativity that went into your blade all
really really good but I think
historically there's a reason that most
bladed weapons have a single blade on
that second blade just winds up slowing
everything down and because it didn't
pass the tests as well as David's blade
that's how we made our decision
thank you Jamie please surrender your
weapon it's validating for me to have
made it this far
thank you now I know I can compete with
guys that have been doing this for 20 30
years hi brother
congratulations David you are the forge
and fire Champion you're going to get a
check for ten thousand dollars
how do you feel man
what a road Dave you've never made a
Qatar before and look what you came up
with your Japanese Masters would be so
proud of your work congratulations thank
you Doug
10g purse
it's coming at the perfect time thank
you very much
[Music]